they're taking a bath in a poisonous
soup of decades of untreated wastewater
from tanneries battery and
pharmaceutical factories and other
industries on which Bangladeshis economy
relies we're fully aware of how polluted
it is but we're both men and when we're
around here this is where we have to
wash now the government is finally
making some progress against the worst
polluters with a high court order
forcing the closure of 231 illegal
tanneries but the pollution continues
licensed tanneries are supposed to pump
their waste to this new treatment plant
but it's not yet fully equipped to
operate at capacity so every day
thousands of litres go straight into the
river
there - the court has ordered us to make
sure that effluent treatment plot is
performing at ultimate level so we're
going to take over operations from the
Chinese who are running it now we end
the government shares the same attitude
and mindset to tackle and handle the
pollution problems 64 freshwater fish
species in Bangladesh are under threat
because of pollution 9 are critically
endangered according to government
figures libera Ganga used to provide
Dockers drinking water now it's toxic
and black and cracking down on polluting
industries is part of the government's
ambitious plan to clean up
Dockers rivers here a market built on
illegally reclaimed land is being ripped
down all this area up to the road will
be dug out again and the river
returned to its original width borrow
our money if there are a lot of
influential people involved in land
grabbing even members of parliament and
big industrialists who own many of these
industries are polluters but at the same
time public awareness is growing in
regard to the environment and pollution
and a strong desire to save these rivers
for years the government has turned a
blind eye to the Garmon related
industries which contribute 20% of the
country's GDP activists hope this court
ruling will set a precedent for other
rivers 38 of which they say are dying
due to unbridled pollution
and land-grabbing Burnett Smith
al-jazeera Daka